MAF you you had a note there to talk
about Avi silverberg the guy that um
broke the female powerlifting record can
you can you chime in on that
yeah I don't know if you want to bring
the link up or talk a little bit about
it so see if I can find it here there
was a uh so Avi was a is a as a coach
for USA or sorry the Canadian national
team powerlifting
um and recently these federations have
been allowing for
um
transgender
women I can't even keep it straight
biological men who identify as
transgender women to compete in women's
divisions I know I can't even keep it
straight now so you know I don't know if
this is because yeah so this is the ipf
so
um USA powerlifting just passed
um that there was another transgender
lifter lifting as a woman from a man and
so ipf is sort of the apparent
Federation of the U.S uh usapl but the
point is that there was this transgender
lifter who essentially broke a bunch of
Records the one in particular that this
person broke was the all-time women's
bench record
um yeah he actually broke the female
trans record like this trans person here
he broke their record and pissed them
off from what I understand too right
yeah so the female trans broke the broke
the record
um which is for one it's really not that
impressive the record that
how much did he bet she broke was only
275 pounds which anybody who spends in
the gym can easily do that that's a very
for someone that's competing in
powerlifting that's very modest numbers
now I don't know what the weight class
is and and
um you know big black maybe nose or can
talk a little bit more about leverages
either way yeah
so 275 is not like so I could [__] that
have to everybody most people at least
four out of five people on this panel
could bench that
um so this this guy Avi uh entered in
another powerlifting competition and all
you had to do
was said I identify and take a box you
didn't have to do anything as far as
provide any blood work you didn't have
to show any documentation show any
papers surgery
you can still have all your appendages
take a box and just say I identify as a
woman they put you in the women's
division and he shattered like eight or
nine records including the bench record
I think he did somewhere in the realm of
like 360 or 370 pounds or something like
that because it's 375 pounds yeah so and
this
shouldn't they do a chromosome check
why would they you just say you're trans
you just say you're a woman
so that and that's the problem right so
he just said he was a woman shattered
all these records while the transgender
lifter the former record holder was
sitting front row and then the
transgender lifter had a complete
meltdown and then went on this online
rant and said things like you know he
didn't do it in good faith or people
like me and I'm nice so I should get to
keep my records it was this really
weird sort of
um Soliloquy about her it's his her
personality and how that's why she
should have so you know what's really
funny to me the bringing this thing full
circle is where I've had conversations
with people that identify as trans
especially it's all and it's almost
always trans women that we're biological
men and it's very convenient to sit here
and say somebody like Avi is oh well
that's just a man who's taking advantage
of it just to say he's he's a woman but
but you get to just say that you know
why where do you get to decide that
because somebody is doing something that
you don't like or you don't agree with
where do you get to decide that person
is gaming the system versus that is who
they say they are why is somebody on one
hand oh they are who they say they are
if they want to use the other bathroom
or use the other locker room or use a
women's only gym they are who they say
they are but the minute that they come
in and start breaking your records or
they start doing things and doing maybe
harm to people you say like oh no that's
not a real transgender person like so
this this double-sided sort of this
double speak right this double standard
is just it's insane to me
enhance off to Avi yeah so I think I can
speak on this because that's kind of in
Alberta is kind of the Texas of Canada
um but I think let me speak to this
there's I think two things that are
going on so the first thing is that like
a lot of women
um have never actually felt the strength
of a man okay so they see movies of like
this you know 110 pound chick beating up
like six 300 pound guys and like again
it's brainwashing similar to what we
were talking about before they think
that's the way that that um
that life works though right I mean Rich
I've told this story before about how um
I was at a an event with a bunch of uh
female rugby players and I said to them
like okay well let's arm wrestle let's
put some money on it you know you guys
think he can beat me in an arm wrestle
and I'll say I'll give you ten to one
knots 200 I'll put down 200 people down
20. it took all their money because they
actually thought they could be mean in
armor so I said like I had an arm
wrestle so then I'd milk them even more
I'm like you can use two hands let's go
again okay big black could you could you
enter that same contest as Abby and
become the first black transgender are
the champion could you do that we should
pull money together and send you there I
wouldn't make sure I would make sure I
called Nike first so I could get a
sponsorship from them and then
yeah you probably get it I could do that
here in the US
I mean I could enter any powerlifting
competition I want but you know remember
member no the best troll ever is is big
black if you do it remember what Jim
Morrison done on The Ed Sullivan Show
uh no I'm not 100 years old oh yeah he
stuck a cucumber down his letter pants
okay so do that break the record as a
you know a female athlete and you know
have have the Cucumber down your shorts
while you're doing it what's what's uh
what's a heavy bench press for like a
strong power lifter because 370 is it's
about three and a quarter plates right
uh yes I mean my guess Avi can do more
than 370. yeah um I've seen four or five
plates on bench bars before avi's
probably in mid-400 plus Venture right
um
kilos that's probably
180 no 180 kilos is like 400 pounds
um so like closer to 200 closer to
215-ish
like 450 pounds is like 250 kilos
that yeah 15. that's at the top of uh
like uh being natural and having to
weight lift most of your life to be able
to reach that yeah whereas like again
somebody that lifts like again
your average a 185 pound 200 pound male
who lifts for a year or two can easily
hit a 275 yell [__] that's not hard
yeah
you know and I think the second thing
that was going on too was that the
female or the male to female powerlifter
she was talking a lot of [__] uh online
though right she was just oh yeah she
was like oh I don't see why these women
white chicks why your benches all suck
okay
and the guys like I'm not gonna put up
with this [__] and he just went in there
and destroyed her because he's like well
[__] you though right yeah you know
disproportionate like if you look if you
take a look at women power lifting
totals like overwhelmingly better
squatters and dead lifters than they
ever will be Ventures and that just has
to do with their physionomy that has to
do with the way their bodies work so
yeah I mean it makes a ton of sense like
I know women that can pull 400 pound
deadlifts but they can't bench you know
200 pounds so like yeah so so again like
that's
it's just it's nonsensical it kills me I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out